la Unión Europea comienza a aplicar la
ley de mercados digitales que busca
velar por los derechos de los usuarios y
que exista mayor equidad a la hora de
competir la ley ha creado la figura de
Guardianes digitales elegidos entre las
empresas que tienen ganancias de unos
7.500 millones de euros dentro del
bloque o una capitalización mundial por
75 millones de euros otro parámetro es
si tiene más de 45 millones de usuarios
mensuales la intención es evitar que
utilicen su peso en el mercado para
priorizar a sus propias compañías como
que el motor de búsqueda de Google
dirija a los usuarios a su página web de
venta en línea Google shopping o que
Apple solo ofrezca Apple Store como
única tienda de aplicaciones así la ley
regulará principalmente a compañías como
meta alfabeto Amazon Según la ley estos
guardianes deberán evitar la combinación
de datos con otros servicios prohibir
que los usuarios deban Iniciar sesión en
un solo lugar o de manera forzada o que
las empresas obliguen a los a que
utilicen solo el sistema de pago de sus
plataformas de otro lado la ley Busca
que los innovadores y las empresas
tecnológicas emergentes tengan nuevas
oportunidades de competir e innovar en
el entorno de las plataformas en línea
Sin condiciones abusivas que limiten su
desarrollo los consumidores podrán
elegir entre más y mejores servicios y
tendrán más oportunidades de cambiar de
proveedor las tecnológicas que sean
consideradas guardianes tienen plazo
hasta el próximo 3 de Julio para
notificarle a la comisión europea si sus
servicios satisfacen los requisitos de
no cumplirlos deberán pagar multas que
serían del 10 hasta el 20% de lo que
facturan anualmente en todo el mundo